as we said in the press
that i was invited to speak to the
transgender employees at netflix and i
refuse
that it's not true
if they had invited me i would have
accepted it although i am confused about
what we are speaking about
i said what i said and boy i heard what
you said
my god
how could i not
you said you want a safe working
environment at netflix well
it seems like i'm the only one that
can't go to the office anymore
so you know there was
people from netflix
that didn't want that [ __ ] on
and everything and stuff
she's one of them
okay that's who she is i'm ashley marie
preston and i'm the organizer for the
stand-up and solidarity rally my entire
career everything that i've done has
been about pushing boundaries it has
been about holding people accountable i
just cussed that asian [ __ ] clean the
[ __ ] up we expect more you mess up my
order and then blame me english is my
first language [ __ ]
i know it's a lot to ask in california
but speak [ __ ] english yet i said it
we also pour social equity into these
spaces we just broke my phone on this
asian bitch's head dave chappelle
doesn't get to suck all of the light out
of that we're talking violence
okay
um
trouble is latino and asian businesses
need to stop being rude and [ __ ]
disrespectful they don't have the same
equity this asian [ __ ] in subway got a
fat ass
no why did you include that that's funny
yo just saying you think you got a fast
oh it gets worse
you're gonna crack the [ __ ] up hold on
[Laughter]
he almost looks like a [ __ ] from behind
hashtag shaking my head we will no
longer stay silent asian hoes act like
they won't get karate chopped and they
must [ __ ] throw just to be clear in
real life i'd smash your [ __ ] head in
like a can of a w root beer dick writer
real yo listen as [ __ ] up as this
she's funny she's funny yeah those
tweets are that's the five
you know she's not an asian [ __ ] so
it's a male which makes it funnier
this asian [ __ ] looks like
asian folks are evolving they're
abandoning the samurai booty and some of
them getting their butt injections in
the dbl's what's good for him
got a fat ass bro i would beat the dog
[ __ ] out of you dick ryder to understand
intersectionality and what it means i
have asian friends but they some
[ __ ] weirdos sometimes hashtag
i said it but we all think it
[Laughter]
oh my days we talking about violence
and you know it i know it we all know it
i just said it because y'all thinking
all right legally calm down obviously uh
ashley murray preston is a great
advocate furry slipper wearing ass [ __ ]
boy keith pretending for the internet
dick writer
has proven herself as an activist good
lord i don't know what's going on there
with bubba
but
no no no let me say this about homegirl
you know what if she abandoned all this
like new age
sympathy empathy [ __ ] logo
she'd go back to being a funny
[ __ ] because them tweets even if
a lot of them are
they're so funny that's some funny [ __ ]
it's a delivery hey you furry ass
[ __ ]
it's the delivery that's [ __ ] up oh
man
i think it's all great that [ __ ]
got a mouth on that but we're talking
about violence right well i mean
listen i don't know how literal she was
or how much that happened also a good
majority of those tweets are from over
10 years ago so i don't really care that
yeah and a loved one too many people and
her
embarkment on activism so thank you so
much these
[ __ ] [ __ ] suckers fat mexican
piss blonde miss piggy looking [ __ ] the
delivery of that is amazing hey listen
you know
some people
arrest
and some people are funny racist yes you
know
i mean the first time i heard doon [ __ ]
i laughed
you said dune yeah he was talking to
this arab guy
i thought that was funny it's like
listen
but if it's sprinkled in with some
creativity i can at least appreciate the
artistry
i'm not even joking i understand
yeah if you're gonna hate
do with some style some penis you know
what i'm saying yeah some pizzazz
exactly put some oomph in it yeah that's
awesome that's all i appreciate it i
love strippers not in like a gay way
[Music]
i love gay men but this county clerk at
window g is a [ __ ]
thank you so much for the invitation
that is the last time i helped that
[ __ ]
so for those of us who are standing in
solidarity with the trans employees
another damn asian almost hit me while
crossing what the [ __ ] is with y'all and
damn vehicles
hashtag racist ass i don't do mexican
nation or samoan we need to have
difficult and complex conversations you
should be ashamed if you take abortion
pills like flintstone vitamins that's
funny
that's that is it it was just funny yeah
if i'm not even trying to [ __ ] expose
a [ __ ] like these people are
doing
it's just it was funny
yeah the whole thing is funny but you
know that's the interesting thing about
folks who act sanctimonious is you come
to look through their closet and
recognize they they engage in a lot of
the behaviors that they condemn or they
engage in a lot of the bigotry that they
call out other people for you know you
can't really say that this person's
comments weren't far more homophobic
than dave's comments could ever be
perceived as transphobic it's not even
close no right what she said is clearly
far worse and yet here she is holding a
rally trying to lynch another man right
metaphorically speaking not literally
honestly but so there's that part that's
interesting now the comic coming looks
at this and laughs because i think it's
creatively done it's funny it's not
tacky right that's me though that's me
you can look at it and be as outraged as
you want and you're completely justified
like i said first time i heard a white
dude say doon [ __ ] i couldn't stop
laughing i think the whole day i kept
picturing desert and i kept picturing
black guy
brown people i just want i couldn't stop
laughing
but again
that's right
yes that but but watching this woman
that's what i get the vibe of a lot of
people love to reinvent themselves and
then persecute the very thing that they
used to be right a lot of people get
older and then look at young people who
are unwise and be like you [ __ ]
idiots like this that was you when you
were 18 too right so i just think that's
the part that's really distasteful uh
most of our tweets seem to be from 2010
2011. one of them was like 2018 so how
do i feel about it not that strongly i
don't really care but that's what i
thought it's the fun yeah it's the same
as well it's just you know you're gonna
go out and just look at look at you yeah
you point the [ __ ] out you got
three fingers pointing at you yeah
that's why i point like this yeah
you appreciate it so i'm i like that
this asian [ __ ] got a fat ass that's
funny i don't know what it is
from behind you look like a [ __ ]
shake my hand
i just laughed but again i gotta yeah
that's funny the delivery is funny i
like gay people but this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's just the whole sentence is [ __ ]
up you know what it's like you ever you
ever have like an uncle say something
so outrageous
you gotta laugh you gotta laugh
god you can't say that
i showed them what i did and you know
what and you know what let me tell you
something and then they unleash it yeah
that's just funny but that's everyone
everyone handles things differently so
you handle it that way but those are my
thoughts on this anything else you want
to say no all right
funny things